you don't remember this I did not yes
you did you used to do that like what
you used to do that bro I I hate [__]
like that that's so awful are you sure
it was me
I
Runk hello
hello
hello hello will you please hello
hell H like if I go I want to put
something on this side or if I'm looking
at that do this that's interest that's
funny that's weird so especially because
you've seen yourself on camera a lot a
lot trust me a lot dude always on camera
self somebody's always taking video of
me and I'm you know and you're looking
at it you're making me look at it and
all that making me uh it's all right
dude we got it it's at 39 it's fine fine
um we uh are chilling here right robot
chill bot 3,000 we are chilling here
relax take a load off it was nice
walking in here for once the uh AC was
actually blasting instead of walking in
and it was sweaty I actually was able to
put on something long sleeve for once
because I always have to wear short
sleeves cuz it's always 10 degrees in
here 100 dude I made that mistake before
what I said 10 when I meant to say 100
what is earlier like before we started
recording wow well I guess that's good I
have a bubble in my throat can you tell
can you tell my voice is higher I can
yeah there's a bubble in my throat I was
sick last week can you tell from my
voice I can yeah yeah it sounds terrible
um so anyway did you want to talk more
about the sweatshirt that I'm wearing
you pointed out something about it that
I didn't think about but it's true I put
it on and you said I said look at how
weird the neck is on this thing and you
said oh it's probably for bodybuilders
it is for bodybuilders well it says body
alive and there's a big buff guy on it
and I'm wearing it and I'm a big buff
guys so you're probably right it is for
bodybuilders you didn't think about how
that was a bodybuilder thing guy a
bodybuilder on it says body alive no I
don't I don't think about they're being
closed for bodybuilders obviously there
are though as you pointed out but I
didn't think body alive that's why um
what's that baby alive is a thing an old
an old an old um toy it's creepy baby
alive Baby Alive where you're like your
own little Dr
Frankenstein I don't really know oh I I
talked about on congratulations once but
I forget what it is is interesting uh or
did we talk about it here about it on uh
on luxury oh we talked about life like
luxury wow and you don't even remember
bad guy bad guy so I don't even remember
what we did right after we did it same
same I'm so that way and when I watch an
episode which I don't watch every
episode but I'll I'll like put one on
every once in a while I think when was
that and it'll be like 4 days ago I know
I know I I I'm like that too if I can do
a song like that baby alive I'll
remember it but if I can I won't the
reason why that shirt's a bodybuilder
shirt is because the neck's big so the
traps can stick out and you look crazy
good yeah and also so that like the tops
are the guys big taters can stick out
right yeah well the yeah top ters the
tops of the ters right the top very very
typic tops of the ters yeah um so anyway
that is um that is a cool shirt I like
it and I wanted it and if I was wearing
it it would fit better because I'm a
bodybuilder now I don't think it would
fit you at all um here's the deal about
the Baby Alive doll the thing that we
talked about with the Baby Alive doll
that is on Lifeline luxury if you want
to join the lifeline luxury go on over
to
patreon.com Lifeline luxury and that is
where you can get the extra episodes
only on patreon only uh for the lifeline
luxury and that's where we do not take
submissions we just bull we bull crap uh
as brothers uh if you want to get me on
tour oh Trenton New Jersey is on live
right now uh is that a new date yes it
is December 1st Chris uh chris.com but
I'm also going to be in uh co wait Cina
and Pittsburgh uh Cleveland Southern
California is Cina Cleveland Detroit and
uh Orlando Florida Fort Meers and it's
just going to be Richmond Virginia and
Baltimore uh Philadelphia reading and
then oxnar dates coming up chris.com go
get those tickets uh thank you very much
and then uh if you have a question or if
you have uh submission we don't need any
more Jordan with the slam submissions by
the way we got a lot of those we're in
inundated with those so go to watch
lifeline.com and send in a video uh you
guys always get the Jordan with the
slam's wrong anyway uh or you can do the
hotline it's below if you want a
one-on-one advice session with Matt Matt
De Leo will give you very very coveted
opinions and great great uh advice great
advices uh Matt toa.com and the lifeline
merch for the purple pimp Pimpin or the
other ones that you want to get Lifeline
merch.com you know what what sorry no
and we're off the other merch that I
really like a lot is the the sweatshirt
the gray one one that's the best one
yeah with the logo very very very nice
Kristen wears mine and it looks good on
her and just very nice material just a
very nice piece of clothing everyone who
wears it looks very
nice okay all right I mean I guess so I
mean there are probably I've seen people
who don't look good in it no I've seen
people a lot of people wearing them and
they all look I will say I will say that
gray crew neck sweater is one of those
things that when people wear they do
look nice
yeah they look very nice you know
sometimes people don't look nicer with
clothes on but that one is absolutely
popping so almost everyone almost always
looks better with clothes on now true
not me I look crazy good naked you
should have longer sleeves on and here's
why what is that what is what oh the
cupping oh that's a cupping Mark why
were you cupping on your arm I didn't
know I was going to be doing it but uh
the guy this guy Anthony came over um he
just snuck a cup on you it no no no he's
a he's a um a physical therapist for the
Lakers and since we're all and since
we're all athletes we're all athletes me
and the Lakers he came over
and and uh he's a fan he CED you he he
listens to Lifeline actually and uh he
uh he was helping me with my I guess
tontis tennis elbow tennis elbow uh
climbers elbow I call it because I did a
rock climbing okay that's actually how I
got it but
um and so he was like do this cupping
and I was like okay had you ever done it
before no have you mhm it's
weird I H I've done it a few times but
all on my back yeah so I never really I
didn't know you could not do you could
do it anywhere I thought You' do it on
my back and that's it oh I didn't even
know what it was what is it is it it's
so it's a local thing you can just if
something hurts you can do it there yeah
and did it help uh I don't
know I mean you're the only one in your
body well because you you have you did I
did it once you have to keep doing it
it's not just like you know what I mean
but isn't that convenient for all the
cuing artists out there I know but uh I
got to get more sessions with him he
said he just texted me I got to text him
back but anyway uh anyway that's what
that is so I don't need the shirts but I
you know I look crazy I've been at the
gym been doing crazy so I'm in a caloric
deficit so it's fine dude what's that
mean it means I take I eat less calories
than I burn cuz I burn more cuz I'm you
know I'm getting rid of the [__] I'm
getting rid of the excess stuff I'm
trying to get my body fat down is that
good though that sounds like a bad thing
caloric deficit no it's fine I mean okay
I'm in good shape but I want to be a
little bit you know in better shape okay
that's good for you good yeah you you
ate a bite of my thing and then you were
like I can't eat this anymore well I
I've been good and I didn't I didn't
want your food but I was like oh that
looks interesting I'd like to taste it
and I tasted it and then I said no I'm
being good and then I just ate rice
and uh uh eggs now that part was boring
well man you just told a story about how
you were you know uh cold and then hot
and then said 10° instead of 100 so um I
bet I'll do it again today look we all
be boring we're boring and that's fine
to be boring as long as it's just quick
in and out right in- and- out boring
yeah Inn out boring forign uh bad sex
in- and- out boring that's what far guy
calls bad sex
um so I Saw The Equalizer 3 oh okay
didn't dude we saw the first one opening
night in the theater we did yeah me you
and uh Chris the other Chris oh right so
many Chris's dude
oh I remember that many chrises in my
life that's so weird man now what I want
to I have a question okay what do you
like better John Wick or The Equalizer
CU they're the same movie in essence
kind of uh I don't think they're the
same movie but I feel similarly about
them okay what do first of all what do
you mean they're not the same movie what
I mean is John Wick is like huge on
Stunt filmmaking and specifically like
violence on camera and like The
Equalizer is much more of like a
dramatic thing where he happens to be a
guy who can break your elbow like in one
swift motion but it's not about the
action okay so you're right okay when's
the last time you've seen either John
Wick or The Equalizer I've only seen the
first ones of both of the franchises
when they first came out yeah so how do
you know that oh because I know because
I just saw last night and I didn't even
think of that but you're right I know
that because people are obsessed with
John Wick it's like become a huge huge
huge FR and the people that are obsessed
with John Wick are people who like love
fight fight uh choreography okay
cinematography stuff like that like
Uncle Mike is like crazy that stuff but
how do you know that the equalizer isn't
that cuz I saw the first one and nobody
talks about The Equalizer but nobody
cares about The Equalizer yeah I mean
they make
equalizer was make money cuz Denzel's in
it and Denzel's the man and he's the
greatest actor ever to exist I thought
The Equalizer was like almost as big as
John Wick it's not I don't think so it
may not be I don't think so but it
definitely obviously if they made three
it does well yeah I'd rather I I came to
a decision I'd rather watch The
Equalizer movies oh oh without question
too yeah oh okay yeah why because of
Denzel Wasington nothing against Reeves
no me too and well you know I'm the
biggest ke reev yeah I love ke Reeves
but it's not the same thing he's just
like a great
Entertainer is the greatest actor of all
time what is the [__] dog thing the
Basset Hound thing he's doing now with
the lip coming look this I think it's
just getting worse with age he's always
had that he yeah but he does it though
he does he's definitely doing it dude in
equalizer it's so low it's like a
[__] fangs coming out the bottom like
you're saying he I always thought it was
just like a yeah I guess I think that
these these actors do that and then they
get known for it and then like it's like
the Bruce Willis smirk it's just like it
becomes more and more and they don't
even know they're doing it now but like
oh oh you know what I mean Al come Chino
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh dude I don't
know he doesn't because he doesn't do
that in interviews Denzel so he doesn't
do that
normal but he's but he's not being
badasses in interviews dude equalizer 3
is he just being so badass it doesn't
make sense or what dude the first shot
the first scene is this guy it's
actually really cool the way they do it
this guy pulls up walks out of his car
the bad guy uh goes into a place a house
in the house he keeps
passing brutalized dead bad guys you
know just like like literally a butcher
[__] in his head like there this is
the opening scene of the movie yeah okay
um people are just like like uh their
faces blown out with a gun and okay he's
fall going downstairs into the second
level down it morb I mean 25 guys gets
into the
basement dude I mean you know where this
is going gets in the
basement two bad guys like this
yeah Denzel Washington sitting down with
the guns to his
head with his
ring cleaning it with a towel
why is that happening dude he's just
like
this but
what like just though like he's waiting
in line at but what at is happening
though you know like what is happening
so that's what's happening but and now
you want to know why he's there you want
to know okay so the guy is
like do you have any idea who you [__]
basically what you so Denzel equalized
and now he's at the bottom he came in it
was a bit uneven and he just equal
equalized everything yeah he leveled the
playing field and that's why as his name
he's The Equalizer okay and he's like
and they're like uh how this's the first
five minutes of the movie that's so
crazy and the guy and the guy's like uh
do you have any idea you [__] with and
he was like he's like now you're [__]
you know because you got two guys seems
it sure seems like he's couldn't be more
[__] yeah right and he says Denzel
says
uh we are where we're supposed to be oh
wow so he's not worried he's not worried
at all no dude he's so not worried like
there's different levels there's not
there's there's not worrying because
nothing bad is happening then there's
something bad is happening but you're
not worried you're like more concerned
then there's oh [__] I'm worried right
and then there
being defensive and being like we don't
have to worry about it I got this but
deep down your word you may not even
know it right but other people can see
it other people can see it then there's
on top of
that cleaning your ring with a [__]
where to get the cloth even who knows
dude he's in the middle of the room the
sun's coming this way through a a
basement shaft clean and he says and he
says uh we all are where we're supposed
to be whatever
by the way the whole
scene in Italian is he speaking in it in
Italy he's speaking Italian how could
you fail to mention that part because I
wanted to uncover it okay so okay so
then
um he he says you're [__] now and and
Denzel says in English I'm not I could
tell you that the I could tell you that
the uh your man to the right is is
holding a gun on me and he's a foot too
close and and which means he's which
means he's already dead luckily those
guys don't speak English nobody speaks
English thank God that was just for us I
guess or he was saying it out loud and
then he then he goes like this and he go
shoots the other guy that was a mistake
goes like this breaks his [__] thing
shoots take the other guy shoots the now
the main bad guy through the guy's face
who's holding the gun interesting into
the other guy's face interesting
interesting interesting interesting what
else you got and then the movie just
starts from there starts from there dud
that's so weird the first one was like
so like it took forever for him to like
equalize anything I after that yeah how
do you remember that after that was my
criticism I was like why is he not like
he's not equalizing he's not equalizing
anything until like 50 minutes in after
that it took really long time for him to
start equalizing again you know a little
Spurt of violence or action excitement
in the beginning of a movie will go a
long way a long way yeah yeah a really
long way it was really actually good the
way they did it um and the movie is good
but equalizer 3 is it the best one of
the three I don't remember bro the first
one is not good oh really but that
sounds good I liked it cuz it was in
Italy uh and it was too it was uh too it
was it was just a lot of Denzel just
like that's all see that's the problem
with the first one all anyone wants when
they go to The Equalizer to see Denzel
equalize endlessly just like with a
straight face just like popping people's
elbows taking people's guns when they
don't even realize it turning it around
and shooting them in the face like
that's all we want by the way first
one's like a drama in the first one he
goes like this you've got N9 seconds and
then right n seconds and good part uh
and then he puts his watch away MH for
the whole movie takes it out when it's
business time at the end yeah right yeah
how funny is that dude that's that's
very Denzel what's funny about The
Equalizer and then we'll get get to some
submissions but the
equalizer is a little known fact is that
that script was like a passion project
for Denzel Washington that's not that's
not like a studio effort to be like well
we need a star to make this movie he
like found the script and he asked
Antoine fuka to direct it at least the
first one I don't know and uh yeah he
did the third one too he's got weird
taste man he does have weird talk about
that here you know he's the greatest
actor in the world but he's got weird
taste yeah all right uh uh just straight
up never done a comedy you know nope he
did work with the Coen Brothers recently
but it was when he was doing MC Beth you
know wow weird uh all right uh all right
first submission let's get going but
that's that's kind of what join Lifeline
luxury get more of that now we get to do
submiss oh yeah oh yeah
patreon.com I mean said it so fast hello
there Lifeline oh oh wearing a cardinal
shirt I know you on my last uh one with
the small
oh my god wow but I just want to know I
need help when we get in Jordan with the
slam wow merch oh got to make it like
those old 9s t-shirts with a little
pocket little Bugs Bunny hanging out
well and we get copyright
infringement oh oh my oh a dad a dad
dude that guy you know what's a shame
it's so funny I thought the same I
thought this guy better have kids
otherwise he's a worthless human being
oh wow that's true he's still pretty
young though yeah well you better have
kids man otherwise just going to waste
yeah he's not worthless but um so dick
but um yeah uh that's a good idea we
actually have talked about it Jordan
with the slam merch I think that that
will be the I think that that'll
probably be the next one that's a good
idea well we've talked about we give you
no credit well we've talked about it
before yeah we have but yeah so so you
didn't actually do anything man so you
know well he thought of it too which is
fair uh and he's uh seems fine you know
and he's got the lightsaber which is
dorky write in the comments how much you
want the Jordan with the SL yeah let us
know uh if you would get the Jordan
Jordan with the SL merch uh that's
pretty good well that's crazy to think
of that Justin McKinnon knew about that
you dude he's going to sue us you know
actually came up with that when I was
eight no yeah he did all right all right
next one who's
next hey guys I just wanted to say I
think I know that guy uh who took
Chris's orders was saying uh think
that's good but the quickest swiftest
way you can possibly say it just work on
it until you eventually arrive at it's
good skip I forget what was your thing
skib the guy would come up the wait no
matter what I would order he would just
like es skib yeah he's probably that
guy's right yeah it's could no I don't
think so I don't think that's right I
don't think that's
right why would he say that you know
what I mean it's good yeah why would he
say that now why would he say well I
mean he doesn't say a skib that's weird
yeah he might well he does though no
yeah he comes out of his mouth yeah I
don't know what he's saying I don't
think it's it's good was that a b big
boy yeah oh the wait's name was utai UT
AI UTI U the worst name ever UTI unary
tract [__] infection his name is STD
all right uh you're wrong next his name
is sad great you're wrong next all right
cool you're
next good day boys big fan of the
podcast I've got a possible Jordan with
the slam here we go um it is funny
interview of Kodak Black where he's
talking to shoman the god and I forget
the context but he says a help though
like in a funny way so now whenever
something happens where a warranted
answer would be I hope so me and all my
friends just always go I hope so okay
yeah so is that a Jordan with the slam
now or is that not it now here's the
worst game show ever
also Chris please come to Australia I
will want to see your stand up very bad
love you now he just said he loved me
that's interesting I love you too okay
uh now listen this poses a very very
interesting and important query about
Jordan with
this so by
all thus far
defined meanings of like what qualifies
as a Jordan with the slam that would
count yeah in my head it counts but okay
see here's the here's why it's an
interesting question stop rushing me
right I'm not rushing you so stop
rushing me and uh it's like it didn't
happen oh right in front of him right
right right it is a public it's like it
was on true something like a screen but
we have but we have ones like that it is
that it is that that's true I think it's
a Jord with slam so it's a Jordan with
the slam and not uh it is that it is
that it is that right no it is it's both
it is that is Jordan is a Jord oh so
there's no delineation between it is
that it is that I I know I guess there
could be I think there's a little bit of
a difference yeah the shorthand we have
talking now I hope people are on board
with what that I mean definitely the
people who listen every they've been
watching they know what's going
on you know what I
mean all right so I I we have to decide
right now you're right okay so I guess
technically the creme de La Creme
Jordan with the Slims happen in front of
you right the creme de creme ones yeah
right but so it still counts as a I
think it's like a second tier Jordan
with the
SL so uh anyway it's a tier two it's a
tier two Jordan with the Slime okay so
that is a tier two Jordan with the Slime
if it did if haveen it in front of you
it's a tier one it's a tier one okay
JW T taking so long to get the acronym
taking so long to get the acronym uh I
thought you guys were for sure going to
say that's not Jordan with a why for the
reason I said Reas for the reason Matt
said yeah right right right I thought he
was going to say that too but he's it's
counting as a tier two it's a second
tier okay tier two Jordan with cool yeah
all right cool for those of you don't
remember Jordan with the slam [__]
Matthew
mod Johnny Bravo Matthew Modine dud
Johnny Bravo's son Tim Bravo gay Matthew
Modine can no one do the Jordan with the
slam another
one no one's getting it save the world
um I had this one guy in high school he
was really quiet and but he was like a
big dude you'd expect like this husky
voice big dude tall but super quiet so
great he knew that he would make people
uncomfortable with his like high voice
he talks like he's deaf and he would be
kind of like out of it a little bit so
whenever he made people uncomfortable
blind he owned it and he just
went it's all in my
head it's all in my
head and come on that's just that's just
the best you're [__] with people and
it always made the boys laugh you know
it's just goofy so if that's a real
Jordan in the slam then uh I win I guess
if you say it though you have to like
the the guy called calling him before
you it's like now it's a thing that him
and his friends say that is a key
component of a Jordan with the slam you
can't just be like that was a funny
thing that someone said once so that's
aord with the slam that's not a slam in
fact just a funny thing someone did once
it also can't be a tier two tier one J
with the Slime if the guy was saying it
to be funny yeah you yeah no that that
is an immediate disqualifier it's a
pretty much a tier three idea yeah yeah
it's pretty much I'm going to put you in
tier for even suggesting that that was
no no but thaty was
what the that guy was Tim Bravo Johnny
Bravo's son and it's all good yeah that
is all
good hey uh this is a question for Matt
deia oh boy okay um so I know he likes
stats like baseball stats and um just
want to ask uh because a Dodger player
named Max I mean it's not Matt but like
Max M he's pretty close to Matt he's got
to have 100 RBI and he
uh he has more RBI than hits and I and I
was just curious if you know
when was the last time that a player had
over 100 RBI in the season while having
more RBI than hits okay that's boring
but um so the question that I actually
want to ask is like I almost ran over
a a pedestrian oh okay the cops are
after me I was inches away and like I
didn't even feel bad and I think they
changed the law in America where in
California where
it's where fell asleep J walkers have
more rights to where it's actually
illegal to run him over well so like is
it bad is it am I a bad person because I
don't feel bad almost killed a J
Walker what did he what okay said he
almost hit him the last person to have
more RBI that hits in a season before
Max Muny was Max Muny so there's that he
did it yeah what wow such an he did it
he did just so dumb you know he did it
twice yeah cuz his whole thing is his
average is always super low but he gets
a lot of walks and hits a lot of home
runs and when you hit a lot of home runs
you got a lot of riby stakes right don't
say riby Stakes runs bed in riby steak
that's really dumb dude riby ribbies
dude riby staks um so this guy almost
hit a pedestrian and he's wondering he
didn't feel bad about it well that is
what we call normal yeah so um if I for
instance mhm took a step mhm and wasn't
paying attention and stepped on my dog
and my dog yelped I would feel bad did
yel RW and I would feel bad if I took a
step and I didn't step on my dog and my
dog was completely fine because I didn't
step on it I wouldn't feel bad because I
didn't do anything it also kind of
depends though on the other person's
reaction if you almost hit them and
they're like holy [__] I might feel bad
right which is why you should never look
at people if you almost hurt them
because then the look they give you will
last with you forever like that one time
you pretended while someone was checking
their mail you pretended to swerve and
like you remember this oh my God I was
in I was I might have not even been in
high school yet I think it was in Middle
School you were driving that black uh
Yukon or whatever the [__] you uh yeah
and you would do this thing where some
you would it's hard to explain you
wouldn't pretend you were going to hit
them yeah but you would like jerk the
wheel at them knowing you were just
going to jerk it right back actually
jerk the wheel yeah yeah you would like
you would like Ste toward them the car
would do it right you would steer at
them but knowing you were just going to
do it right away not going to kill him
yeah but they don't know that cuz all
they do is see a car barreling at them
and this guy was checking his mail and
I'll never forget he was so scared and
like you he looked up while he had his
mail in his hand and and and you
obviously like swerved back onto the
road but he didn't know you were going
to do that and so he like like his body
was like ahead of his legs and he tried
to run back toward this his house and he
slipped you don't remember this I did
not yes you did you used to do that like
what you used to do that bro I I hate
[__] like that that's so awful are you
sure it was me I I don't know who I
don't know who else it could have been
it definitely wasn't mom or dad and the
only person that was ever driving me
around was you besides that I can't
believe I did that dude I have I have no
memory of that it was on uh Vero
Road it was literally right on that road
like before it curls up back into uh
Foothill [__] bro and so now what was
what did so you looked at the guy I
looked at the guy and he was so just
abject Terror dude just absolutely he
thought he was going to die fully
thought he was going to die the male
went in the air his legs went out from
under him he
fell I mean the way you probably forget
is because you blocked it out of your
memory cuz you felt so [__] bad how
would I have forgotten that I'm telling
you why because your brain was like we
can't allow him to remember this is too
much but that was something I would do
yeah and actually I think you stopped
doing it because of that all right well
at least I didn't do it after that no I
don't know CU I wasn't always in a car
with you but yeah I just do it alone
yeah [__] guy got him got him Terri
[__] his mail he should be that is so
thing teen you I know I know but that
sucks I don't believe I did that okay it
was Dad
it was mom like this yeah I [__] got
him n dude it was you but it's all good
all right all right well repentant you
stopped so yeah no way I feel so bad if
I did that I I feel so terrible I felt
terrible he was like I think he was like
of some kind of maybe he was Armenian
Middle Eastern some oh so he deserved it
wow I felt I actually felt even worse
because you don't want yeah you don't
want him to think you're doing it
because of that but I do equal
opportunity I almost I I scare the [__]
out of equal opportunity people I don't
give a [__] what color race or Creed you
are I'm The Equalizer when it comes to
that okay well that's makes you shitty
all around the board I got a few white
guys o let's get this brown guy yeah
like that yeah that makes you terrible
to everyone okay
cool next all right next
one a horror movie camp campsite Su man
sup Chris whoa just sending in my Jordan
with the slam situation from my past
used to play online games with this guy
and after every sentence almost this
dude would say n just kidding he didn't
say n just kidding he said
nashin every time that constantly oh
that that's 100% Jordan with that is oh
Brian K is my favorite comedian nashin
yeah nothing worse than
that absolutely don't do that nashin nin
but nashin is great think every three
mons that's such a good for the past 15
years that's such a good Jordan with the
that we would adopt that yeah
nashin nashin died uh anyway hey the
video's over you know Dad on the Pod at
some point let him give his advices I'm
sure it's great he's got a lot but
that's just for
us you're done I yeah done the video was
over for so long hey heyy the video's
not over nashin um that's a great Jordan
with the SL he did it we finally have
done it we've achieved there you go a
full tier one top tier Jordan with a
slam yeah nashin and it's not a nashin
it's it's definitely not
nashin you're not just kidding that it's
Jordan Sun like all right cool yeah just
a tier one four
alarm Jordan with slim
okay what
to wow I mean just just straight terets
just only T didn't say a single word bro
this is why I like this podcast is we
have our own way of talking you guys are
our friends I don't give a [__] about
these dumbass podcasts man we Lounge out
we have a good time and we Lifeline dude
yeah we lifeline and dude that is a top
tier for alarm four star
yeah it is absolutely great dude 100%
top
tier dude that's great crying dog when
you do
that y all right next one hey CH M
Freddy Mercury uh I think I might have a
Jordan with the slam moment Freddy s um
for you guys back in high school I had
this friend that would always say I
guess in replace of the phrase eff it
instead of saying ah eff it um he would
say ah F get Thailand F get Thailand
kind of in that Cadence Tha ah fuget Tha
Thailand and one I was assumed he got it
from movie or a show because he was
always that kind of guy to to take
phrases from from from shows or or or
anything like that and to the way he
said it I guess me being stupid I always
assumed it was one word and I think I
asked him about it and he was just like
ah it's just something I said it's [__]
it Thailand yeah and it was always funny
to me way he said it the Cadence in
which he said who get Thailand it didn't
take me until recently I would say well
not recently probably like 7 years ago
yeah um recently enough I guess that I
was dating this girl and we wanted to go
on vacation and she was like uh oh how
about Thailand
Thailand and I was like oh that's cool
how about fuk I think that's how you say
it properly fuk yeah and I'm looking at
the the flight and fuk at Thailand wow I
can't believe this oh fuk Thailand wow
and it kind of clicked in my head and it
brought me back to those times where he
would always say it in the the
situations that he would say so I kind
of wanted to ask especially you Matt the
movie buff did he take that from a show
or a movie or something or is that just
something he created no he just created
it and you know what how I know he
created it I did a bunch of dumb [__]
like that too remember when I used to
say what are you go of toning about yeah
it's just like people kids dumb little
boys get [__] in their head and they
just they think one thing sounds like
another and then they start saying it
and then they never stop saying it ever
I bet that guy still says fug get
Thailand that's so I would have loved to
seen his reaction when he saw the thing
wow that's really funny that guy
honestly is the wrong Hue he looks like
a more he would be a white guy he's the
you know have you ever seen um what's
that uh White Lotus he's the gay guy in
White Lotus but Brown oh oh season one
yeah yeah I know you're talking about
that guy though has such a good way
about him oh yeah the way he was talking
and like the body language
that guy is my friend okay well that guy
is a is is it a Jordan with the slam
though not really cuz he didn't do it
doesn't do with his friends it was just
all internal no no no that's just that's
not even a tier it's also the guy was
trying to be funny so it's not really a
top TI uh but I feel a kinship with the
guy Okay cool so that's good that he
called in yep there you go all right
what else we
got hey guys Vinnie here from Cincinnati
I think I have a good Jordan with a slam
moment for you guys so my best friend
and I work out a lot together and we
were working out with my other friend
and my one friend wanted to comment on
how wide my other friend's back was
which is kind of weird to begin with but
Chris you get it you're a wide guy looks
like filmed the Lord of the Rings on
your back we all know that but for some
reason he couldn't think of the word
wide it just wasn't coming to him it
wasn't clicking so he went up to my
friend and said hey man you're really
long this way and he did this with his
hands and those words came out of his
mouth and that blew our minds and we
died laughing and long this way has
stayed with us since then anytime we see
something that's like big or wide we'll
be like that thing's really long this
way that's good so hopefully that's a
good Jordan with slam for you guys feel
free to incorporate into your lives and
um stay long this way it is except for
the fact that if the guy didn't like say
it in a funny way usually usually it's
like you get to do the impression you
know what I'm saying yeah you know a
great Jour with the slam is what the
[__] you doing what what the [__] doing
what the [__] you doing right that's a
great J with now you have to tell a
story okay so yeah I I played soccer for
like two one or two seasons when I was
like 12 and my friend Morgan daki [__]
Japanese kid I love this kid right and
we were on the same team he was the
goalie and I was the whatever the
[__] guy is right after the goalie
the defender
right somebody was uh coming up
to uh score I was bad at soccer okay and
I also am a cut up I didn't give a [__]
so everyone wanted to win except me I
didn't I honestly did not give a [__] uh
worst defense and so um the ball was in
the air and I had learned that you could
do bicycle kicks I didn't learn how to
do a bicycle kick by learn that you
could do bicycle kicks that they existed
yeah so the ball went in the air and I
thought quickly my CH my chance to do a
bicycle kick I went up went upside down
kicked the ball uh with my shin but
Morgan was going for it and he was gonna
get it and instead of him getting it I
kicked it and Morgan seeing the
disastrous effect which was going to be
probably or at least 50/50 shot scoring
on ourselves in own goal Yeah in our own
goal Morgan as he was jumping I remember
it [__] clear's day with his gloves
his goalie gloves he was saying no no no
Chris what the [__] you doing what the
[__] you doing no Chris what the [__]
you doing what the [__] you doing and
dude and I did the [__] and we
actually scor it scored on our goal and
we lost we we the other team got a point
so the only goal you ever scored was
against yourself but also I was a
Defender so it's not like I was going to
score for us but yeah so what the oh
what the oh what the [__] you doing so
defensive but so yeah well I'm a
Defender so true yeah um anyway yep to
this day I'm defensive so uh so that is
a true top
tier right it really is that's right
yeah so any you're welcome for that
that's a good one too I think about that
one sometimes what the [__] you doing
what the [__] what the [__] you doing
the slam and swins remember that one
twins twins are we have a bunch of
different Jordan with the slimes twins
twins I haven't thought about that one
in a [__] while I have thought about
it recently wow okay I mean prob we ago
competing with me so I'm up on the DNS
SN one all right let's go next one hi
Chris Matt I'm calling from Montreal
Canada Chris I was not able to come see
you when you were here but hopefully
next time you come I'll be able to make
it
um so my situation that I need advice on
is about this guy that I just started
dating he's wonderful like I have like
there's no even red flag so far he's
he's great the only thing that he does
that really gives me the ick is he does
like that L Cool J lip bite where he
licks his lips and like bites his lip
and I think he thinks it's so sexy but I
find it so so cringy and like it it
really like it really gives me the ick
how do I go about dealing with that
because he does all the time and I don't
know how to tell someone hey like when
you do that yeah that's so funny that
this guy's such a has no idea she's
laughing at him appreciate any advice
you guys sex thanks so much bye dude
that's what a great submission let me
tell you something too that's that's
might be like the best yeah submission
we've ever gotten which makes up for all
the [__] Jordan with the SL videos we
had to answer about so
listen uh
it's
so bad that that guy does that anybody
who's not L Cool J here's is it even
cool when L Cool J does it though no no
but at least he is kind of came up doing
it if you're doing it it's intrinsic to
who you're sexy it's bad but if you're
doing it because you think l Cool J is
sexy when he does it well I don't that's
way worse but that's not what she's
suggesting no but I know but you're
obviously as a dude if you're a good
dude that's like yeah you're doing it
because you seen other dudes do
it you're
gay I mean that's what you do you you
see another D doing that you're like oh
that works for him I got to start doing
that you think I don't know though I I
mean May it's certainly possible but I
don't know if it's necessarily true okay
so say there's different levels of how
how horrible it is if the guy's White
saw his lips off you're saying it's
worse if he's white way worse okay it's
so bad to do that brings me back I think
I agree but why is that true because any
time a guy thinks he's being sexy or is
trying to be sexy
yeah Mr you're you are now labeled Mr
keeps it dry because there are dude her
[__] is going to to be drier than you
are pretending your lips are okay don't
say [__] in seriousness in a
conversation no cuz I don't want to say
p ussy cuz we'll get demonetized okay
you could also say Hatchet wound oh the
pink stuff no okay whatever fried
butterfly just say vagina vagina I'm not
a doctor but vagina your vaginal cavity
is now drier than your pretending your
lips are F Hatchet
wound you know what I mean so grotesque
you're sideways Burger all right
whatever you want to no well nobody
wants to call it that whatever you want
to call did want do that uh but wait I'm
ask I wasn't asking about that I was
asking about why is it wor why is it
worse if it's a white guy oh I said I
think I agree but I don't know why why
is that because it's something that like
people of color like men of color do
they just like it's like yo well I mean
okay so when coj does it is it sexy no
but it's sexier than when her [__]
dumbass boyfriend is doing it yeah oh my
god dude I mean I mean maybe it is sexy
when Alia does it though people that
well some women do
Dumbo people that don't actually have a
brain and are like oh he's doing that
because he thinks it's sexy they don't
know that you might get it I have a
question actually why the [__] would
anyone think that that is
sexy it's just [__] kind of gross
it's reminding you that the mouth is
there and that's used for kissing but
that who needs a reminder of that that'd
be like if Al was just honking his dick
the whole time yo what up Ma just broken
it yeah I mean that would be at least
more direct but like what is what the
[__] this is so I mean I know men do
this and it's not like a new thing it's
not news to me but that is I'm thinking
about it in a certain way now and it's
so weird it has to be because of the
eating the the vaginal cavity eating oh
boy okay it has to be because it reminds
you of what what that mouth do you know
what I
mean now that's sexy how you do
it um but that's why my I I started to
do something that never caught someone's
mouth is dry
like Bird yeah um dude that is the that
oh oh I feel cringe and I'm not even
looking at you this was a phone call
that she wrot I that you called in for I
just hear her I'm C bro it's so funny
she's laughing while do while telling us
she has to laugh otherwise she'd cry too
much she's laughing at the dude and the
dude thinks he's being sexy and she's
laughing at it
that's the worst thing as a man yeah
generally I mean I know what you mean
but it's better than some other things
though no no but generally men are
afraid to be laughed at yes that's true
yeah that especially a guy who does that
yeah a guy who does that is not looking
to he's not like us like we laugh at
each other all the time that guy
probably takes himself so any dude that
they take so seriously she says he's a
great [__] guy though except he does
that so here's my advice actually if
he's such a great guy
mhm tell him like if he's so great I
mean I'm not like challenging you on
that I'm saying if he if he really is I
bet you can't if he really is then I'm
sure he'll be like look at a certain age
I don't know how old you are maybe
you're in your early 20s and it's not
really applicable but she sounds 30
something yeah she does yeah so if he's
like you in his 30s
like we're big boys at this age if you
don't like a thing that I do that I do
either without consciously realizing it
or even worse I think specifically it's
to turn doing I'm doing it to turn you
on and that's not working I want to know
so I cannot do it he he yeah he wants to
know yeah but you have to let him know a
guy there is no man in history that has
the uh self reflect that has the
how do I say this any guy that does the
licking lips thing in all seriousness
doesn't have the capacity to
own yes I do that because I'm trying to
be sexy okay well then they do not then
might I suggest something slightly
different okay what you should do is
say something like and that's the truest
[__] I ever said something like hey I
noticed you lick your lips a lot I'm
curious if it's because you like are
your lips dry draw attention to
it but don't like say how much you think
it's disgusting I think you should I
think you should draw attention to it
and be like oh it's interesting no I've
just noticed it and make make it clear
that you're not noticing it as something
that you think is either sexy or not
sexy that you're noticing it as like a
bodily function so then he'll realize oh
if he is doing it to be sexy he'll
realize oh that's not
working okay if you want to be indirect
about it that's the way to do it no I
suggest being direct but if you can't I
understand if you can't do that it's
your situation not mine it's in front of
you you know the guy better than I do I
would say every time he does say oh
that's not sexy or there's that version
Oh that's not sexy dude that is that I
can't I actually it's tough to think of
something worse honestly think of some
worse things genocide yeah but we're
talking about in the realm of this is
like I I I I I
I just feel for you and uh wait I'm now
for some reason I'm like BL does he lick
his
lips oh God it's gross it is gross it's
not even that it's not sexy it's
specifically kind of gross hey why do
you do that why do you lick your lips
you do it all the time yeah yeah yeah
just say that yeah yeah why why do you
do that you dry dry lips it's weird cuz
when you do that my Hatchet W gets dry
so maybe we can get some dual chapstick
stuff going on maybe just work your [__]
on my sideways Burger dude sideways
Burger why don't you work your [__] on
your myz burger and we're both we're
both better for it right let's see that
look cool Jay oh look look at the no the
top oh dude unbelievable dude wait hold
on no no no don't click anything
un [__] believable he clicked that
one there is an there is an Ella Cool J
lick count with a counter in the bottom
left and he doesn't C that one he
clicked a different one but this is a
compilation I want the [__] counter
one dude yeah he wants the counter one
world knows now ABC now like get out of
my house man L was always licking his
lips my house doing it so
bad me L okay kic that guy's ass so hard
if you saw him do that here we go I mean
not news what the [__] is this
program oh
thank you Willis that's the thing came
uping the skinny a few months ago I was
making fun of
LL always is licking his lips no matter
what he's doing singing hosting whatever
and he did the same thing again at the
Grammys when he was hosted on Sunday
night so thanks many thanks the good
folks over Jimmy Kimmel show because
they actually had this funny setup last
night what happened more Ling hosting
the Grammys or using the word amazing
during The Bachelor so take a look at
this let's do
it that song music's biggest night and I
show had to change
Wow E okay he's doing it cuz he has a
dry mouth period he's not doing it to be
sexy no he's doing it to be to be
[Music]
sexy that he did that to be sexy come on
okay uh go to the go to the uh lip dude
do you know how many times Jimmy kimel's
made me laugh no absolute zero wow
really yeah okay well man I mean when
you look how long he's been doing it
he's doing it to be sexy dude how could
you not yeah cool I'd like to some cases
I think you're really just seem
[Music]
to you
know how about this one how about this
one how about this one how about this
one when you did that the video the
Hat
the I me the last one someone was
getting [__] destroyed you know
[__] hell was that someone was
getting their [__] throats lit all
right well he licks his lips too much it
sure looks like a tick when you look at
it that much and if it is then I feel
bad I don't think he's doing it to be
sexy man I don't think I don't think
he's doing it consciously you know what
it is he started when he was younger
doing it cuz he thought was sexy and he
did it so much cuz he thought it was
worth working and now he can't live
without it and it's honestly he made his
bed and now he's got [__] now he's
got to keep doing it cuz now it's a tick
he's developed a tick such a ridiculous
like yarn that you just completely made
up no it's not true if I was a therapist
that's what I would tell him well
there's a reason you're not a therapist
it's because you're not qualified to be
one and so what you would tell him is an
unqualified bad wrong opinion how's that
feel when I said that I'm a therapist
how's that feel it honestly yeah doesn't
make me feel any sort of way at
oh he's uh he's got a tick and your
boyfriend it I
mean you're judging it as something he's
doing that he thinks is sexy I'm I defer
to you break just break up with them
that's a problem and you need to end
that as soon as possible just break up
with them make him self-conscious about
it if you can't bring it up directly but
you got to you got to do something about
it cuz otherwise it'll eat you alive and
it'll make your relationship bad and
then you'll end up breaking up with him
for some other madeup [__] reason or
start to do something that he doesn't
like no fart a lot around you're going
to make it worse that way that's not a
solution he's like why you been farting
a lot damn why you been F lot why why
you look at up lot let's P stop right
like you're trying to pull out mm yeah
okay yeah that's a bad idea too though
um all right well look Sunday it's
Sunday and uh go sign up for Lifeline
luxury uh um patreon.com Lifeline luxury
Trenton is on sale now New Jersey I'm
coming home I'm coming home I'm coming
home you know I'm coming up Chris
chris.com and a bunch of different ones
Baltimore uh Philadelphia Cleveland
Covina I'll be there um and uh
Pittsburgh and Detroit uh Detroit
christ.com and then
um the uh oh do it stop with the Jordan
with the slams you get what it is now
enough is enough uh we're not going to
do them anymore watch lifeline.com send
us a submission or the hotline uh go
ahead you want a one-on-one session with
me I've been saving lives these last few
months with these private sessions I
don't know every Tuesday and Thursday
saving lives saving lives saving lives
mata.com book your session with me
totally private with just me oneon-one
hello hello it's good oh yeah and then
get the merch get the merch or you hate
us Lifeline
merch.com
Jordan what a
Sal
hello
hello hello